I saw you living that you had a you got
a big white soon got on you had a like
in the world right there crazy like all
[Music]
right so we on we're on brother
I'm like knife in this is hot boxing and
I'm here with Edmund bread everybody um
two distinguished guests here we got a
couple of great guests we've got former
Navy SEAL Jeff gum awesome dude
thanks for having me guys three it's an
honor and then we've got the man Kyle
Maynard huge inspiration I remember
seeing this guy on ESPN probably ten
years ago and just what an incredible
story man it's awesome to have you guys
in this is a pretty surreal moment for
us both to be here with you guys so
thank you thank you yeah you were my my
hero growing up you a grizzly and uh man
grew up in Georgia yeah so I've been out
in California for five years now you
like it out here yeah I do but I've kind
of been I don't know I'm just on a
journey lately got rid of most of my
stuff and I've just been going around
tell me about that you know sometimes I
go through that I think anyway I think
I'm I have too much you know I'm not
deserved this maybe that's my width
we're thinking of something tell me
about that that years yeah sure yeah no
I just made a conscious choice to
basically the only thing I put value in
is this frog necklace that I'm wearing
is kind of the main thing I have a Bible
that my grandparents gave me when I was
a kid and other than that you know
there's a few other things that hold
meaning to me but I just it's not that I
don't I can't ever want to allow myself
to have possessions or whatever a
property I mean like that the the the
branch that you guys are building is
amazing is phenomenal and that's so cool
and a dream you do that if not for Rhode
exactly
the world you know so that's kind of my
thing is I just don't want to I don't
have any desires for stuff that I want
for myself I just have desires I want to
go and do for the world and live life
and build dreams with my friends and my
you know best friend Navy SEALs you know
we got a swimwear couple together it's
just a real experience of their life
lately that's so awesome man I mean I
think that's a when you really Whittle
life down to what's most important it's
not about all the [ __ ] and the
things and the material it's about what
you can bring to the world you know and
the contributions you can make to your
fellow man and you guys have been on
some [ __ ] incredible adventures
together and you I mean you've hiked
Mount Everest dude yeah coming Jonathan
tell me about that it was it was a good
dose what did you see the animals up
there when we saw at the Safari but you
start off in the in the rainforest and
you go through every natural climate
zone in ecosystem while you're there but
in this start off in the rainforest and
then ten days later you're on tundra and
I bare crawled it so I had bath towels
when I first start hiking I didn't do
Kilimanjaro in man what did you see what
did you see man saw the biggest trail of
ants I've ever seen in my life I saw
just I mean beautiful landscape wide
open plains and it's being on that like
this the glacier and the snows and
Kilimanjaro was was just it was so
beautiful it was because the glacier was
receding right as the earth is warming
then it's glaciers receding and so it's
it's going to be unclimbed Bowl at some
point or not unclimbed Bowl but it'll be
a lot less accessible because that the
glacier is the main water source so the
hardest probably the second or third
hardest physical day of my life was
going up the what's called the western
breach and that was just one 12-hour
brutal day climbing about 2,500 vertical
feet of elevation gain to go in and
sleep inside of the crater rim and the
trade-off was if we made it on that one
day going up through that we couldn't
turn back so once we set off we had to
keep going but we would cut off five
days of the total trip time and since I
was bare crawling
my arms and my feet were so swollen and
jacked up I was in so much pain I was
becoming angry at the fact that my
buddies were having fun and and I was
envious of that and I'm like I'm not
having very much fun at all right now
and but I I knew that if we could take
that western breach route I could I
could suffer through anything for one
one day but I knew that the additional
five days to go around to the east side
of the mountain and then up to the
summit might be the death of me so I
just did it and that one day and bit
down as hard as I could and you know we
didn't have ropes and started ice
climbing and you know it's not straight
ice climbing but we're hiking up this
ice field in the middle of the night
slipped on the ice probably three four
o'clock in the morning scared out of my
mind but made it up and slept in the
crater rim and then that next morning we
just had a nine nine hundred feet to go
for that last summit push and it was
almost kind of a victory lap at that
point when did you um by any chance
partake in that toad yeah first time so
the the the frog itself this this frog
has showed up before me in different
things I actually I have not yet gone to
the toad in the way that you have I've
done several ayahuasca ceremonies now
I've had some powerful psilocybin
experiences that have changed my life
and given me an entire new perspective
and I've been I've been waiting for the
right moment to go there I do believe
man that like there's there's more to
this this physical realm that we're in
the web food weren't given the right
information ya know we're told about
Columbus and all these creepy guys all
the wrong information about who we
really are
and who we really come from and stuff
you know hmm so true man and I think
people yeah I think people gonna find it
for themselves you know they tell us
they told us one time there were only
five thousand years old folk for a long
time we believed there were only five
deme found cities underneath your other
city that a 9,000 years old we can't
explain that yeah we can't what happen
to another 4,000 years that girl Gobekli
Tempe have you seen that your site in
Turkey
20,000 years old or something like that
people are building massive in the
pyramids and we don't have pyramids in
Bosnia that's older than the pyramids in
Giza and Bosnia they older than the ones
that the distinctive stuff in Bosnia we
don't know who we are we don't know
nothing [ __ ]
yeah and you know at the same time I
kind of almost at this point for anyone
that claims to know I wonder what
experiences they've been through and
unless they you know it if you've had
some deep experiences with plant
medicine and you want to talk to me
about what is I'll listen but without
that I'm not interested anymore in
hearing your scientific materialist
reductionist view of the world I feel
like these guys miss the big picture of
what this is really all shining felt
nine foot Caucasians yeah the Giants
yeah like a giant to me face of
scorpions is - blond hair blue eye they
made it with the Chinese pit Chinese
with even taller and the more the woman
with seven feet yeah
these are know yeah some people refer to
those creatures as the Nephilim
yeah they were angels that angels came
down and breeded with the humans and
they created these Nephilim these giants
that would terrorize the humans yeah and
they they're I mean if you dig on the
internet you'll find weird research
articles or
papers on fire yelling the NASA Weaver
where these people come from
I know maybe a [ __ ] couple with blond
hair blue eyes will he come from
I never thought no guy that big that
looked like that well let's talk a
little bit about that plant medicine man
and the knowledge and the information
that that gives you access to have you
read a book called the cosmic serpent
now let's say the Platte Madison was fun
compared to the toad the toad takes you
right there that's them play with you at
all it takes you right there what you
got what you made out of boom yeah I
heard you say when you're on Oregon's
podcast you wanted to keep going back to
it yeah kept coming out you know I
didn't understand what was going I just
died another experience that in my life
I mean most people do that one time and
they go away and I was like only Mike
Tyson would have that mentality to just
go back to it like oh I just died but I
want to go do it again now it took me
someplace even better even better Kyle
Mike finishes his second trip it was
like a [ __ ] storm man like lights
were flickering it was like there was an
exorcism happening and after Mike's
second trip I went in there it was like
thirty minutes after he went in and have
a look at him in the room the rooms
totally dark I see Mike sitting at the
back on the couch totally chill with a
joint burning in his hand and he just
looks at me I'm like Mike how are ya
he's like they won't let me do a third
he wanted to go again so then like back
to that he wanted to go he wanted to go
number three wait I say heroes and
cowards feel the same yeah would you do
to make you to hit on but you don't do
that makes you the coward
absolutely well [ __ ] maybe just um I
wanted to hang out there for a while
to the grasp of understand them we
didn't you weren't afraid of dying then
you know I mean all my life I've been
afraid of dying and stuff and all this
young lovely I'm missing all this money
I'm a mess I was watching Mike dying is
justice girl aureus is living because I
mean you couldn't have life without
death yeah you know you guys meditate
life is better when I do yeah you know
it goes more smoothly and I try to try
to just bring it to my life you know and
and just I don't know be just I think
what I try to do instead of meditation
is I try to listen mmm
be in the moment try to listen and I
listen for things that other people
might not listen for and in terms of
even today you know in meeting some of
your crew and the standing United mm-hmm
you know I I know here that I mean this
is it means such an amazing honor to be
here with you guys I think that the
highest truth for us and the reason why
we're here is was really to meet them
hmm amazing dude you you diagnosed that
already that you're but you know I mean
that kind of is very cosmic that you're
here man of course your spirit animal is
the Frog you know why what else would it
be coming in here right you know what I
do Jack's by two last week anemic
Guardian money deuce that sounds like
your problem man I don't care go rob a
bank okay put some money down and win
like a man the matter with you man this
is that [ __ ] and going on right
now
my bookie online [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] him
how many years mine pokey online because
I think that [ __ ] from them hell no
that's right my bookie online you play
you win
that's what I'm talking about done all
day every day let's do it my bookie
online boom
[Music]
my bookie online has better bonuses and
more prop bets than any other sports
book period sign up for a chance to
receive $1,000 bonus at my bookie online
today
that's my bookie my B oh okay ie and
don't forget to use the promo code
hotboxing to activate the offer Geoff
man dude you're a Navy SEAL I told
they'll take you to that level man I
think that other dimension of the
chamber of life is gonna be a
psychological trip it's gonna be really
happening I'm back goodbye coming my
kids they're really happening with it
whoa it's really crazy - he was on a
Vision Quest and as Thailand right no in
California it was just a sober shamanic
my first exposure to shamanism and he
ended up on the back of a frog that like
brought him through brought him through
the river well I said that basically it
was just this visualization that said
you're gonna discover your spirit guide
in this and I'm looking okay cool it's
gonna interesting whatever in ten
minutes nothing happens it was just
drumming totally sober and then all the
sudden I was holding hands with this
girl and looked over this hole I got
sucked inside of this hole travelled
through it and I got shot into this
river and almost I was drowning and I
lost the girl and I was drown him like
wow this is crazy visual for not you
know being sober and then all of a
sudden I feel a cement block underneath
me almost like your cement floor outside
here
it raises me up and I'm writing on the
back of the Frog and then I put it
together he's got a tattoo of on the
bone frog which is to memorial for
fallen seals mmm his were frogman
frogmen I'm looking holy breath at your
bath long longest I did was 308 yeah
when I was in Mom's and buds it's the
only time I really you know
underwater and was like was testing that
usually three minutes eight seconds
you know I'm three minutes is around the
box you know how much damage you could
do in three minutes
imagine it that's crazy
that's crazy Jeff have you experienced
any plant medicines yourself psilocybin
suicide yeah really you know I've had
I've had amazing life like a lot of
incredible blessings but I've also you
know I lost my little brother when I was
eight I mean I lost my father when I was
eight I lost my little brother when he
was 23 would have been I think six years
ago lost my stepfather recently lost my
boss and I ended up like doing CPR on
him for like 30 minutes so I've had a
lot of loss of my life and it's really
kind of helped me like deal with that
and kind of brought me to a better place
mm-hmm the psilocybin helped you yeah
get through that or at least take
something away from that yeah and just
learn more about myself no doubt these
medicines will show you that for sure
man I got to tell you guys I meditate
every day and I've died a thousand
deaths man and life has become this
constant process of letting go chanting
you know anytime that you think that
you're identifying with something it's
like time to [ __ ] let it go because
we're not that you know yeah or
something so much more profound
you know we're everything we are part of
this whole thing we're all in this
together you know we're all one and I
mean I don't know once you sort of come
to that realization life gets in this
[ __ ] Material Plane that we're on
life starts to get pretty [ __ ] weird
you know I mean I'm also an empath like
I feel everything that people feel
you know I feel it in my body and
sometimes it's extremely overwhelming
but you know it's my gift
it's one of my gifts it's my blessing
you know in this life and so anything
that I can do to make this world a
better place like that's what I'm here
to do it's so cool that that you get
that I mean both of you embody you know
I mean really I guess it concluded all
four of us and this was real man I don't
know you guys quite as well - the camera
crew but these girls are cool
these guys are seem pretty cool - I mean
but you know the attitude and mindset
around masculinity is one that is so
misunderstood because you can be
ferocious but you can learn to be at
peace you know it's all about peace and
love when it comes down to the situation
it'll comes to peace in love my whole
life I was talking about ferocity
viciousness fear inflicting stuff and
all my life I found that that was a lie
and I found that was all about being
humble and serving and giving the people
and loving people and forgiving people
from mistakes and [ __ ] and coming to
grips with that it's just so
overwhelming you know sometimes I cry a
lot because I you know I've been living
the life that was wrong wrong all these
years and now I mean I think you can
show so many younger kids that are going
through that same thing oh you know
maybe they don't have to go through the
same oh absolutely it's a big part of
what drives me I tried you know at ten
years old I tried to hang myself and no
um listen um brother I came here to talk
to you about that because you know
because of my um I mean my my psychology
at the young kids world what I think
about doing that to myself in line all I
do think about hurting people do you
think I you know me I'm not a I'm not a
tough guy but that's all I've been told
is doing them I'm torn sometimes yeah I
don't want to kill myself too you know
everything I did wrong gave me riches
and wealth everything everybody else I
wanted and but I just want to be like
everybody else
that make sense does oh but you kind of
became the doesn't make sense to the
best of everybody else you still wasn't
enough
yeah that's why sort of fear motivated
and secured motivated and stuff I still
have a lot I still have a lot of emotion
to having then came to grips with and
stuff because of that you know yeah and
you think it was your family that kind
of helped bring you bring you bring that
all to light family and yeah pretty much
you know you know things that said to
people and I want to do the family [ __ ]
your mother you what you know what the
[ __ ] am I doing this is for competition
this stuff we were getting well this
should be fun why am i mind think
anything because I never really
understood the concept of love and they
Belle's feelings when significant
because if they feelings were
significant I probably wouldn't hit them
as hard as wanna hit the miss heart so I
added the value of what the value of
why's their feelings I remember when you
retired you said it was because I'm a
father now I want to love my children I
don't want to just train and be a
fighter exactly an animal yeah you know
it's pretty wild Mike I don't I don't I
I met you the night that you fought
Kevin McBride really yep I remember
listen you came up to the boy well with
that look there you came up there how
amazing is that
yeah awesome what were you doing there I
was I was with a guy who's kind of
helping me out helped him get my story
out there initially and and we parted
ways but he was really instrumental in
helping me in those in those early days
and he was the type he would just
navigate through anything to go
get there you know I would be more
reserved and laid-back but he knew that
you were my hero I got to meet Oh like
I'll leave that night too
yeah and I remember when we made eye
contact just the whole cuz Layla fought
that night too
it was just the whole freaking room just
the world stop for a minute and you know
when I got to meet you just stayed with
me because I thought you know this is a
guy who just sat down in the seventh
knew that this is it and you were the
kindest athlete I'd ever interacted with
and I thought the perception that the
world has of this guy's so wrong and and
I mean in a way though I get that with
me you know that the body that I was
born into in this life was you know it
was just it was a different different
one and one that you know I didn't
understand and the early goings but now
there's nothing you could give me in the
world to make me go back and do it again
but a lot of people misunderstood me too
you know so I wanted to be that warrior
i football was my first sport that I
played I wanted to be a Navy SEAL I
wanted to be Mike Tyson and Dan Gable
and you know all these warriors and
Randy quarter and and now it's you know
in my own in my own way
I've gotten to be come back and be here
with you and now I'm at peace awesome
you know I always had that conception to
of being a warrior you know being around
custom motto and him introduced me and
the concept of reading about King is
calling it Alexander the Great and all
that stuff and in all those concepts of
which I've had a consumption of you know
in order to all those things that we
battle for like you know the war with we
battle for honor and stuff but at that
time you never know because they don't
teach you that you put on with honor you
know you don't have to fight oh you can
um you can take it away
yeah you can't win on it you gonna lose
it good you born with it
that's so powerful man but we get to
show people you me a different way you
know that's what I love I love second
chances a lot of comeback stories for
people I love people that recreate
themselves to one of my one of my heroes
is Maynard James Keenan
you know from tool I mean I just said
[ __ ] it like I'm not doing music anymore
I'm just gonna go and make wine what you
know just as he had the courage to go
and to do that man doing with it
I don't know I've ever he's doing well I
think he's doing pretty well yeah he's
doing well it's awesome man
but I mean he's he's doing it though you
know he's walking that path in the same
way that you guys are too you know you
expose yourself to criticism what was
the quote that you shared with me that
he said last night it was it was if
you're a friend to everyone you're an
enemy to yourself oh and I guess that's
Mike dude it's so true man like you it
wouldn't matter like in a way that's it
they like you don't really like you you
know how can you be friends with anybody
you have to come to reality I don't like
that guy for doing this he's abusive to
other people I don't like him and I mean
so how can you say I like everybody in
this guy's doing something that's really
um unworthy of human conception yeah you
know yeah for sure mo and I think
everybody is just interested in or in
love with the image of who they think
you are you know I mean very few people
know who you really are you know
everyone every one of your relationships
in your life you wear a mask of that
relief after sanity
you know nihilism really [ __ ] nuts
you know went out from a normal
perspective you know he's got the Navy
SEALs there they seen people die there
maybe in participating in people dying
you don't think normal than the normal
without here that's working and getting
a job you have a family they don't think
like that experiences may vary yeah yes
so they deal with a world with so many
different entities though but I do
believe it's it's you know people so
much of it is just go on your journey
you know that's what I'm learning right
now is to give up who I thought that I
was for who I you know who I am and and
to find that to go inward more in and
out and really I just spent you know the
spectrum of friends that I have I love
and they couldn't be further from each
other one of my my best friends was born
with HIV and she lived a rough you know
kind of early going mom died at four and
Lexi Gibson is her name I just spent the
last four days with her and she's she's
amazing you know she was basically
orphaned at 13 grew up in Oakland only
white girl going to school you know that
all-black school and it was just a
really if she had a program though that
taught her about the hero's journey
Joseph Campbell's teachings and taught
her about the a lot of Toltec wisdom
from books by Don Miguel Ruiz and Four
Agreements mastery of love v agreement
who's Don Miguel Ruiz is a huge hero of
mine too well so but they basically that
saved her and gave her a chance to come
back and she's you know now you know
she's she's working as a dancer right
now and she's she's she's funded a like
like a non-profit for a year that helps
kids with HIV in Africa
well that's so long and I'm you know
what it's like her heart though what
she's taught me is is is to love thyself
and then you can love the world and you
know in a way it's like I am that and
I'm also you know Jeff and you know Jeff
and my are one of our best friends my
brother Mitch Aguilar Jeff and Mitch are
there they're basically like my Tyler
Durden essence like they are Tyler
from Fight Club you know they dress like
you want a dress they fight like you
want to fight [ __ ] like you want to [ __ ]
I mean it's yeah but to me it's you know
it's both it's the duality of you know
it doesn't have to be one or the other
doesn't have to be so serious we can
have a good time but you know just be
honest with yourself be honest with
other people tell the truth the more you
tell the truth and you you you refuse to
to really bend who you are for for that
truth and watch your life change watch
things around you go in in Mathis keep
your word though absolutely I'm a little
my a mean stuff our hardest hardest
addiction more than any consumption of
drugs alcohol it was being truthful to
ourselves you know
nobody lies more than the drunk addict
you know he tells to choose by accident
clock that's wrong tells ya I had
something to say but man I mean this is
like so [ __ ] awesome I forgot about
it so how did you come to the plant
medicines Kyle like when did that sort
of journey spark I mean for me I don't
get enough of ahead if I had a research
that has access to it I would do it
every day hmm
I don't have enough I think that you
actually what I'm learning is and we
talked a little bit about this outside
but I I think that what they do is is
that they they alter our consciousness
to the state where we can achieve those
you know even with marijuana or whatever
it can elevate your consciousness I
believe I can elevate you know your
vibration and who and what you are you
know we are electricity we're energy I
mean I know that that's so esoteric it's
so out there and I know all the
physicists in the world or rolling their
eyes
I don't really care anymore true you
know it's the in the the ancient Yogi's
they knew this thousands of years ago
know Jesus knew this that's why I was
able to go and help heal people you know
I mean there's and that's thanking right
I
mean to interrupt but you know they
found something a mommy and I could read
that for thousand-year-old money - they
found cocaine in their hair yeah they
don't stay dumb they don't make cocaine
in Egypt so they did it probably in the
ancient time it was an ancient stream
their strain their the head that they
had tobacco - and they don't make the
backhoe in um he had cocaine in this
here Wow 2,000 years old we know nothing
yeah it's crazy man and then other
people like I don't know if you guys
know about if the cocaine them if you
wanted to look it up do you know about
dr. SEBI yes he discovered the victim
for aids yeah he did use fasting fasting
is another thing that's brought me to
new level yeah I'm gonna fast - fast
everyday I'm talking extensive fast
doctor said he was having people fast
for 40 he had Lisa left eye Lopes fuses
fasted for 42 days I mostly do it for 30
days every year Wow
but you can eat at night though it's
Ramadan yeah I'm talking straight fast
straight fasting just alkaline water
I don't whatever Barry I think that's
too extreme eat from Granger then that's
what long as you get from grains and
shout out to the smashing greens or
buddy Mitch started that that's what got
me going is Mitch green greens I'm down
25 pounds right now in two months well
and it's amazing man I feel phenomenal
the last month of my life in March is
the most spiritual month of my life and
the fasting brought me closer to it not
yes it's it really fathom at the high
first this is your mind we're hunters we
grew up on the plains of Africa you know
well when you're fast your brain
releases this stuff brain-derived
neurotrophic factor which starts
creating all these new pathways in your
brain and healing your brain and soaking
up all the toxins and destroying all the
I don't think I don't think that we were
all Junaid and originated in Africa I'm
talking way back in the plains when we
yeah that's our history that's our roots
you know that's what we are
yeah but we're more than that even you
know my green haven but I do think that
that's where we were born
have you guys heard of the Emerald
tablets now tell us about it the Emerald
tablets are it's writings from Thoth the
Egyptian god of wisdom and he it's the
story is that he was a priest in
Atlantis who was granted access to the
other dimensions you know where
reincarnation happens and when Atlantis
was flooded he flew to Egypt and built
the pyramids and underneath he created
this thing called the halls of Amenti
which is where you can go and
reincarnate and come back and he
reincarnated they say as this guy hermes
trisys
yes and founded the hermetic philosophy
and the Emerald tablets are these actual
physical tablets they have found that
are 30,000 plus years old and he wrote
this and when you read these things you
can go buy it on Amazon
my book and it's us it's basically an
epic poem which talks about life and
what this thing is that we find
ourselves in and it's some fascinating
[ __ ] man and like you were saying like I
mean we used to think we're 5,000 years
old you know like there's so much more
to this my wife didn't even want to
dream I think the aliens were involved
with our production how they do this
stuff
I never thought big they were I know the
stones were well think about what we
were so far away from where the pyramids
are built if we showed up to another
planet we would totally if we saw a
primate or something like that I would
be like okay let's go and stick a little
our DNA in there and see what happens
yeah help you build it's employed you're
there that's what they did
no you know what I think you mentioned
Islam too and the thing that I've
learned from that mostly and I try to I
try to be indiscriminate and all the
spiritual teachers that I learn from but
Muhammad never stopped seeking you know
the [ __ ] stop seeking knowledge every
subsequent knowledge because they never
thought that he had all the answers and
it's no wonder how do you have this is
very scary you know the places in Russia
and Ukraine took I looked at you could
did they find warrior Amazon Queens yeah
woman she um she had all jury had all
weapons and she was like this and at the
bottom of her feet was a slave a man and
feed the position of she was on his back
it was crazy and her horse was there to
see a horse they buried her with a horse
it was all muffled mummified huh
it was mummified yes Wow crazy no those
are bones I'm in a tomb or something
yeah there's another city underneath
foot ancient city underneath the country
well my tongue bang talked about how you
saw the Aztec temples in the air towed
yes Thor
I sort of Aztec temple I saw those
hieroglyphics in there and stuff yeah I
thought like um a penile gland
you know the shell of the man there's no
it's just like we show the man the glans
right yeah the third eye that's what it
was well I wanted Tony Robbins out I
forgot that I thought dear yeah that's
what I saw when I took you know he has a
painter in this yeah in the basement
really
Tony's Tony inside a ride with the tow
he's a good man
- I love Tony man Tony was one of my
really heroes actually I I feel bad
because I've I judged him for while some
of the things that I would see and
sometimes I would see other motivational
speakers and stuff like that and I don't
know I'm like the speaker who doesn't
really vibe with most motivational
speakers the anti speakers speakers but
I really I hearing that from you is
pretty pretty amazing I trust you're
both really believed in what he's doing
you know I mean look at some guy look at
it's a business this is a business I'm a
brand oh yeah of a personality yeah I
know I've I've I definitely have
resonates with me a lot Kyle you know
look at things and I mean you say things
a does for people and not gonna help his
brand but his brand is gonna help these
people yeah yeah way he that that stayed
with and I'm really mean if he did
anybody but then I could help with
branded brands what its gonna be right
if you hate it on it you didn't like
that he loves Libby was gonna be and he
use it to help people it was more I mean
a matter of I went I went and sought out
and studied under his original teachers
the founders of neuro linguistic
programming mm-hmm and became an you
know hold this certificate of a master
practitioner of NLP that was kind of
what started my early journey I was at
NLP thank you look at that frog vision
and you know I just I like loyalty and
respect and the fact that you know in
martial arts and the martial arts
tradition you have a lineage that you
come from and you get in in philosophy
you have a lineage that you come from
and spirituality you talk about the
lineage that you come from and you gave
respect
and honor those those teachers that came
before you because you do stand on the
shoulders of literal giants and that we
would not be who we are without that and
that the speaking world in general
sometimes absent of that it doesn't they
don't talk about the the and give the
complete respect of the teachers that
they that they've had now I'm not saying
that about anyone in particular you go
but it's just like that's what people
think that they came up with all this no
we have been evolving this for a really
long time the best we can do is take it
a little bit further yes
you've just been granted access to it
and it's a privilege yes it's funny too
a lot of the stuff he talks about with
NLP is actually real similar to things
we do in the SEAL Teams and the
intelligence community yeah talking can
you talk a little bit about that because
I know the seals they're [ __ ] you're
tapped into this type of [ __ ] what kind
of food did the seals eat I mean we have
a fried chicken top of your game you're
ready to be Beth to do fun to accomplish
something what do you eat well so I mean
sometimes you only get MREs or like
quick stuff because you're you're living
out your living out of your bag or
you're living out on a Forward Operating
Base and you might not even have cooks
so sometimes you don't it it can be hard
other I mean other times if you're if
you're in a more established area then
though they'll bring in that will
actually have locals bring in like you
know chickens and food and be eating
more fresh is your backpack it all all
depends on the mission we're doing
there's times the backpack can be a
hundred twenty one hundred fifty pounds
of gear when you're going up huge
mountains plus machine gun plus yeah
plus your carrion if you're if you're
like a new guy and you're carrying the
automatic weapon it can be thirty thirty
thirty-five pounds and then another 30
pounds of ammo body armor it can be it
can be in a lot of years yeah and you're
just hoping for a chance to shoot your
gun so you can lighten all the ammo he
and himself he's one of the most
mentally tough human beings ever exist
and that's why I'm giving mother stuff
to keep you on the water man
I mean it's usually you like oh tasks
that you're given so yes we're doing it
tapping in your [ __ ] face huh yeah
absolutely so it's like art you go down
and you're supposed to tie tie a knot
underwater this when you're going
through the training and then you tie it
they're like alright how many knots can
do it once I'm like well it's planning
to just do one cuz I want to make sure I
pass one go down to the next one but
they're like alright do three I'm like
alright I go down I do I do all three
knots like get the okay for each one and
then I like request to go up is in like
15 15 feet down and then we he starts
giving me the sign to do
rock-paper-scissors so now I got beat
him in rock paper scissor while I'm down
there and then go up I get a couple
breaths he's like alright let's go back
down and then had to go down tie the
next the next couple do you learn the
people who still have something that
show the chip Aeneid had me long out for
you oh yeah there was couldn't because I
so I so I had like everything go wrong
i I liked Friday before hell week I had
I'd passed
I Pat like six weeks into training I had
passed everything then hell weeks about
to start on Sunday where you get an hour
and a half nap on Wednesday hour and a
half nap on Thursday and he finished up
on Friday so and you run about 50 miles
with a boat on your head you lunge for
miles with 2,200 pound telephone poles
and so Friday before this training
starts I get viral gastroenteritis and I
can't even drink water without throwing
up just throwing up non-stop and that's
what you need yeah so they just put like
IVs in me finally finally I'm able to
get some fluids that way and then I was
able to start getting a little bit of
food down like Saturday night started
hell week on Sunday but then from being
so dehydrated then going into hell week
it led to me getting rhabdomyolysis
where my yes muscles broke down so much
that my blood became toxic it typically
only happens to people that
brushing on your urine yeah typically
only if you get crushed in a car
accident or earthquake and uh I had that
one here in training camp damn it was
hospitalized multiple times really
random yeah once for rhabdo they Clinton
they diagnosed at his rhabdo but his bad
dude full-body cramps in the [ __ ]
parking lot and the bath accomplishing
all those um those details and in your
training methods and stuff you must feel
like a [ __ ] warrior God huh yeah it
was dying yeah you're a bad [ __ ]
dude they they ended up pulling me out
and performance dropping me on an hour
from Wednesday I was the last person to
not make it through that class and and
but I basically refused to accept it and
called up seals I knew who had mentored
me and they called in and vouched on my
behalf and I went to the leadership like
the leader instructors and just like
begged for another chance and told him
I'm like hey I never failed anything and
I got extremely sick before hell week
you can talk to medical I got another
chance started all the way over again
and then instead of passing everything
like I did the first time before whole
week I now failed everything because I
still had rhabdo and he didn't we didn't
know what it was so now I'm like now
it's like affecting me more mentally
because it's my body's not working and I
knew I was strong but then you save us
being like being stabbed in the knew
your legs with you with knives when
you're running yeah so we're running
everywhere you go you have a boat on
your head and it's I'm you know when
like football players get cramps on the
field and they get like carried off MMN
I'm having cramps in my hamstrings and
my and my quads at the same time and I'm
just doing everything I can to survive
to stay under this boat and I think
doing everything I kind of stay out of
the boat is what led to me getting
rhabdo yeah and then then once I got
like rhabdo then I couldn't even stay I
couldn't even go as fast as the guys
that had the boat on her head and
normally it
ever been diagnosed before because
everyone quits when they get it but I I
knew who I was I knew I was strong like
here and here I knew I was just sick and
and got got dropped talked my way back
in started again and then failed
everything again but then I ended up
going to medical and that's when he drew
my blood and my blood came back toxic so
then I started all the way over again
and then uh but now I was used to doing
everything with my body failing and now
I was healthy so it was just now I'm
just laughing and enjoying and having
fun of my friends working out on the
beach it's I'm like you know going you
know going around it's like an adventure
with my friends and I knew I had already
completed all these tasks because I
wasn't like great at the water I trained
a lot in the water but I wasn't but
after doing this training so many times
I'm like just another day doing it again
and and I finally had fun with it and
was making jokes in hell week and I'm
like wow he'll weeks a lot harder when
you don't have wrapped up the first you
ever ran furthest with in when I was had
made it through buds we were out in a
out in a desert in the Mojave Desert
it was like 140 degrees during during
the day like I think 130 air temperature
140 surface temperature and so they had
us we had there's like a 18 mile ruk ruk
run you got to do and I think it's a
three hour time limit how much will you
got on it's like 70 pounds but you're
doing they do it at nighttime because
it's only 100 degrees at nighttime but I
stepped in a hole with seven miles left
and mom and like destroyed my ankle
level-3 sprained and I like and I feel
everything just rip and and I'm just
like waiting I'm like waiting for a
medic and it's like taking too long and
I kind of had that buds mentality where
if I stopped I was quitting and I just
like tighten my boot and just start like
dragging my foot behind me for the last
7 miles of the run and uh
and and and I think I had like three
minutes left and I was gonna I was like
a half-mile out or something and maybe a
quarter-mile and I realized I wasn't
gonna make it and I start like running
and like swinging my body in all the
craziest ways I was like running like
Forrest Gump basically trying to try I
didn't even stop for water anywhere on
the once that happened because I didn't
have time I knew I was going so slow now
but I ended up making the time by like
15 seconds and then I couldn't I
couldn't walk for three days and they
were gonna roll me but I got up ended up
getting a brace I turned in my crutches
for a machine gun and I just started
land warfare again just limped my way
through the rest of the next like three
weeks so I would say it was like very
you know it's like these experiences
like that were even I said I can't apply
it to every bunch of missions beyond a
few missions yeah first deployment was
to Iraq yeah and going after ID makers
and everything it was it was a slow it
was 20 2010 2011 so it wasn't you know
how did the Iraq war anything but you
know going after not going same from the
heat you know my living conditions I'd
say my room was about this this size
like maybe 15 feet and we had AC in
there I was actually there it was more
during the winter so it was like seven
months more more wintertime it was
definitely getting really hot but it
wasn't the heat wasn't so bad cool or me
like it's just a different mindset to it
like you were saying like normal people
would never [ __ ] this change country
where I know you're [ __ ] foreigner
and they know you dare to look for
somebody and you know you have to do it
you still have to accomplish that goal
normal people would just [ __ ] break
down you wouldn't even make it you know
but you know you train I mean you train
three and a half years before you even
go and do your first deployment as a
seal and you're so highly trained it's
like you know how long do you practice
with your team to you know get a chance
to go the Superbowl you know once you're
there or how many years did you train
before
you got your first heavyweight fight
you're not you're not scared you're
excited to be there I mean me it's all
jacked but it's and and I knew I was
there going after guys who were trying
to kill good people kill America and
blow people up and we want to go get
them in the middle of the night and it's
[ __ ] badass how do you know where to
get these [ __ ] there yeah no
way - yet right I mean we definitely
have very sophisticated intelligence
network there we talked though we talked
to locals we and speak Farsi or no it
was Arabic where was that but we we use
in and turquoise interpreters okay and
they're there a lot of these people were
you know they were group grew up in Iraq
but they were had been run out under
Saddam and then they came back as
interpreters and they had been there
they would be there five six years so
they they were very you know they they
knew the people we were working with who
we were getting our intelligence from
and everything we were tapped in yeah so
now I'm the thing was [ __ ] people up
his own people gasp the Kurds
yeah attacked Kuwait fun yeah good day
and who say I just stood right on his
crumpled palace
Saddam yeah there's a philosopher those
Sam Harris brings up a really
interesting point you know if you grew
up as Saddam Hussein's son what chance
do you have you know it's such a product
of our environment absolutely that's why
we've got to change the environment I
disagree with Sam and the concept of
free will I believe that we have it but
I think we have to go in and shift the
mentality because kids that grew up like
you grew up we grew up in very different
families yeah and I would have been
completely [ __ ] had I grown up with
the family that you know that I had
comparatively exactly you know I would
had no chance hmm because the this would
have been too much hmm I think it's over
the will of the way you know I mean I
mean this was already enough with the
per click and amazing manling right
there's people given up every day though
right now you know suicide is's is a
thing that that that that's a real issue
and it's crazy that you open it up and
saying that you felt that before -
there's so many people that are given up
giving up hope because and I think they
give up hope because they don't they
think that this is all that there is
they also give a hope because they don't
think that they can do anything about it
but it can it's about the world they're
in you know Scituate I know gentlemen
that is mine in neighborhoods I come
from in the city I know neighborhood
where people are in your situation they
live like God people will die for him
people kill for them he's just how need
had he lived their life independent
environment it depends on how that makes
you think about yourself
you know maybe that happened to him
anything whoa I need people to help me
so I can't fighting these guys and now
he has the army you know me I don't know
what did he do to get that army Holly
because how do how do they converse to
these people he convinced these people
who protect them put their life on the
line for him how do they do that when
they seem in that situation not like
they could help him he can help them
with Delaney but it's something that he
has that makes them do it that you just
can't put your finger on it all your
best friends are Navy SEALs
bodyguards now I know you're saying my
friends oh yeah that's the thing that
people don't realize how lucky I am
I mean that's how I wish that people
treated each other the way that's real
you know you want to get them didn't
know some guys look at you see you see
my [ __ ] see behind it okay cool well
it's because of that your spirit man
through spirit and who you are
well let's see for each of us though
right yes no it is but I'm saying you
know the like what Mike is talking yeah
you know you gather people because they
believe in you and they love you oh you
guys I love you guys too
thank you thank you so you guys have a
pretty badass swimwear line
huh and he brought you brought Mike and
I some speedily we did my friend we're
gonna be out in Desert Hot Springs with
the Sun ghazan Mike I saw you live in a
single life our brand is called single
life and I saw you living at you had a
you had a big white soon got on and you
had a the world yeah but tell us a
little bit about that company that you
guys have so I I went down to Brazil I'm
real close with the Gracie family and I
saw everybody wearing these soon goes
down there and and I was like oh wow
these are cool and I'm talking to a
Brazilian girl and she's like oh I think
they're so sexy on men I just and I
realized I'm like all right I buy ten of
them and and I realized it's just like
how guys look at girls wearing Brazilian
bikinis they they think it's sexy I
bought a bunch of them started wearing
them all over the world
Croatia yacht week Australia Vegas
issues pretty much this amazing and I
didn't even have to go and like talk to
girls anymore I just like be walking
around my friends girls to come up hey
hey cool I'm like alright and then and
then I was transitioning out of the SEAL
Teams
and I wanted to get in a business I did
this it's called the honor foundation it
helps seals transition of the private
sector and I realized I'm like I need a
launch Mountain company right now and
I'm super passionate about the swimwear
I see a huge niche it's all about
freedom right there oh you got a right
you're having some pretty good times
there to my friends that have tried you
they like to build the people in there
with the value value back to people and
stuff oh [ __ ] that's crazy that's but
it's kind of we like to say to if you're
going to peacock do it like a patriot so
it's all about representing like freedom
at the same time like our free our
swimwear is all about freedom and
expressing yourself and not letting
anything hold you back in life even if
that's a pair of board shorts no and
because you can there's so many Bennet
you got way better tan lines you can
swim through the water really fast you
dry really fast
your life s ung a.com yes
so Tigers are always your thing Mike no
listen I'm in prison one day I'm in
prison one day so I'm talking to my car
dude cuz I'm like it's continuing to go
anyway so I'm talking my car dealer and
we're talking about getting me some
cards when I come home and he's mad as a
couple of my friend he possessed their
cause because they haven't finished
paying them and he said they don't
finish getting my money I'm a seller
cars and buy some pests like some horses
and you know some lions or Tigers what
they have lions and tigers you could buy
those yeah I know finesse Club I'm Cubs
I got horses llama Louie what Mike I
said now look at some cups he said he
don't worry about I guess some he called
the guy when I came home there was two
cubs at my house Wow until these guys
came and I stole stole one stuff right
there this is it right here absolutely
you start and click on men swimwear
men's okay looking sexy called the loud
mountain patriot flamingos Baywatch BAE
and then we just launched our women's
line as well and cat took the same fun
patterns we got
starry night gum Vango with the peacocks
peacock oh yeah forgot a peacock do like
a patriot and if you click on the
women's swimwear women's it's awesome
guys and little did you know this was
like the preferred Navy SEAL uniform and
the old yeah didn't it didn't even like
click till I think couple like maybe a
year they don't really look nice and
never came yeah that's my girlfriend
Bianca yeah way to go Joe she's she's
amazing we just got back from a trip in
Cabo and got like tons of amazing shots
and everything down there we got the
Patriot shades those words we have
polarized and floating bamboo sunglasses
with the Stars and Stripes laser notice
neither do that they had the most
dangerous jobs get the prettiest girls
dangerous [ __ ] it's evolution
yeah tricks like that whoever's gonna go
out and confront malevolence though you
know I mean what takes courage one of
the biggest reasons I became a seal is
that I could always protect my friends
and family and just anyone around me
that if you know you grow up you watch
all these different movies and all bad
people are always doing stuff I want to
make sure I can always stop that person
and I was never gonna allow myself for
people I care about to be the victim
maybe that's something that happened
because my father passed away young but
anyway he was killed on car accident he
was a he was a dairy farmer and was out
picking up some equipment end up tractor
trailer basically came across the
highway and there wasn't much of a
median and just hit him head-on in the
door and he's never had a chance
oh yeah I was eight years old I mean
what do you remember that day absolutely
I was I was
with my mom in the kitchen and my
grandma came in and she was just like
Jeffrey was killed and and like
everything changed
finance change I mean we had a we had a
farm like within probably a month or so
every all the cows were auctioned off
all the farm equipment was auctioned off
luckily my mom ended up meeting an
amazing man Denny and he he ended up
they they got married a couple years
later and he raised me and he was an
incredible father but he and he he was
like a top engineer but from playing
college football he had a head injuries
and he's got early onset Alzheimer's
around 52 years old and then passed away
by 62 and but he he was an incredible
father and you know raised me in
pleasanton sisters yeah my sister Julie
she's uh she's a dentist dr. dr. gum
owns gum dental and uh gum dental calm
but she is they must stay here
Pennsylvania in like Lehigh Valley
Poconos actually Larry Holmes had a gym
right where I lived do it exactly yeah
we're like 10 minutes from Easton and
and I had a brother I had a brother
Chris who he was like my best friend
growing up and we played every sport
together he was the most incredible
athlete but you tell me he passed away
yeah he uh when he you know he he was
like the most talented of all of us he
was gifted he was star soccer player
broke every like record for goals and
assists and and was prom king everything
but he
he battled with addiction and and like
overdosed like numerous times until
until it was my mom found him just alone
on the on the floor it was it was
terrible I know is she's been through so
much I think it was you know just a
couple years after that where my
stepfather passed away as well so she's
she's been so strong through everything
[Music]
where's your mom live Lehigh Valley as
well fancy Pennsylvania yeah you dig
back to see her yeah usually I'd say
three or four times a year to
Pennsylvania but then we also they're
coming out for Easter just to see me and
for a week and my sister has a dental
convention in San Diego and then we just
did a ski trip to Colorado her my dad
actually met as ski instructors writing
up right in the Poconos my dad saw her
and skied up to her and goes you won't
be my partner and and they were I mean
my I had a I'd amazing you know like I
said I had amazing life amazing but like
you know life's all ups and down since
you don't want the victim mindset you
want to be thankful for the time you had
with them and then keep making them
proud and keep you know going out and
finding new new brothers and it's
awesome but I just have to I'm when he
passed away I was like I have to live a
good enough life for me and him now
that's some powerful [ __ ] Jeff which
then to meet you know the united united
we stand
so the you understand you know yeah yeah
i mean i just learned about that today i
don't even know what what are they doing
these guys are guys that have great
support for guys on some mental
illnesses and homelessness yeah
pitching an addiction just them
resources getting them back on their
feet living all my life in a normal
society you know yeah nothing they have
um they have outlet they have people to
cry with that people have to support
them they're people that won't give up
on them ever never ever give up on them
yeah yeah they're doing some awesome
work man this has been like one of our
[ __ ] best episodes yet it's been a
real pleasure to have you guys man is
there anything else you want to talk
about Mike you have any more questions
how did you found awesome and I thought
you know yes that thing I would to like
me a real life on life turns and stuff
yeah yeah yeah
this is I just this is one of the best
moments of my life
thank you guys thank you thank you Carl
thank you thank you Jeff yeah thank you
guys it's very surreal and amazing
experience and you know like I recently
went through a transition coming out of
coming out of the teams and I know you
guys have both been through that from
going from being you know the youngest
champion and and transitioning out and
now having this incredible business and
you coming from the NFL and becoming a
speaker and having being a part of all
these incredible things going on here
and and it just like so many people they
a lot of times they do they do one thing
and they they're they're afraid of that
transition but people can constant
maybe recreating themselves and
sometimes they think like the best the
best years are behind them but it's so
important you never have your memories
be bigger than your dreams and and you
can use that incredible life you already
had to be the foundation of what's next
basically which basically I'm starting
to do I'm working on doing this yeah
yeah second act so to speak right yes
second act is I love that this is gonna
be really interesting to see his bumps
yes one here one last crazy story all
four yes all right so this is how how we
met so I was almost engaged to a girl
and my grandmother was dying of a brain
tumor and I was gonna lose her and she
was everything to me so I tried to rush
this proposal I tried to rush this
engagement and so I I had planned a
proposal for Valentine's of 2014 or
something like that anyway
when I went to go and check in for the
flights for her nice flights from San
Diego to DC the tickets were gone and I
called Delta and I was on the phone with
him for two hours and then they said all
right we can we can read book you
tomorrow but they're storms on the East
Coast so you can't come today so it's
gonna cut a day off the trip and I then
I stayed didn't propose knew that it
wasn't right ended up dating a girl
around the corner for a while fell in
love with her who he ran over her
friends Achilles tendon I didn't meet
her yet at that time I hadn't met Rachel
and so then I but I ended up breaking up
so I broke up the girl Lauren that was
with the time that it was almost engaged
too and then the night that we broke up
fought she left I went to the back porch
and I cried because I was thinking like
oh man I you know left Georgia came to
San Diego and I'm breaking up with this
girl who was in love with and I cried
and thinking I don't have my own friends
and so I want to like I want to create
my community of friends
and so then that next night I met Jeff
went out to shore Club and I was there
with a bunch of my like SEAL team
buddies and I'd seen Kyle's story maybe
14 years earlier on real well fourteen
years from now but maybe like nine ten
years earlier and just thought it was so
amazing so powerfully became one of my
heroes it was like Kyle and Pat Tillman
were like my heroes and and there's all
cendars I I mean I used to think about
him when I was training jiu-jitsu
getting ready even like getting ready
for deployment and stuff I'm like you
know what if I get blown up overseas I'm
just gonna be really strong for my
weight class the way Kyle is and then
all sudden cause belson I'm out at Shore
Club and I see Kyle Maynard like go I'm
like Kyle Maynard what's up man he's
like oh hey and then we start talking
and became like it was like almost I
think we talked like three hours that
night or something like his other
friends whatever he had just worked out
I was a Navy SEAL stuff man cuz I wanted
to be a seal so bad I had no idea Jitsu
I mean there was all kinds of
connections you know it was like he's I
ended up I ended up bringing him of my
work to my work a bunch and I'd I was
training all the like seal all the guys
going through SEAL training how to fight
and do combatives and prisoner handling
and I'd bring them in and show them show
them Kyle because I want these guys to
know like if anything ever happens to
you overseas you can still live an
incredible amazing life and so Kyle
would come in and I'd have Kyle I'd pick
out the biggest guy in the class and
have Kyle grapple with him so I got
video on my phone that's six foot eight
like 260 pound guy in him and concise
yeah then the Kyle have a leg up I've
done grappling yeah I haven't done you
know we should have spicier death
dude but I mean if anybody's drinking to
try and tell me that that your guys
meeting was a coincidence go [ __ ]
yourself yeah this is [ __ ] spirit at
work right here you know oh man
oh whoa woman it's a cosmic man like you
you had just had this intention of
forming your new group of brothers and
Jeff is like I just want to be kind of a
nerd yeah because he's such a massive
inspiration to me I mean dude that's
that's just you know you want to hear
the final the night that the night that
his dad passed he was he told his mom
his mom has become like a and I should
become like a second mom to me third I
have a couple moms that are like really
close to me anyway
so but she had given his mom or his dad
had given his mom instructions on to go
get the Terminator movie and the weird
connection with that is is like that's
what my dad named me after Kyle was Kyle
Reese like the original protagonist of
The Terminator to go and like go back in
time and warn people about you know the
relationship with technology and like I
love that who and what they're doing you
know and that's for me my whole life I
would be nothing without tools but now
there would a of you right like it's
tools that have allowed us to go and
build all this stuff and maybe because
for me when I had to go and put my socks
on for the first time it took me 45
minutes and I used a paperclip in my
mouth to shape a fishing hook to go and
pull the sock on and that was how I got
my sock on but now it takes five seconds
so it I think though that like part of
the part of the deal with that though it
was like right now we've got to decide
as a species what tools we're going to
go and use in the future
do we go down that road of artificial
general intelligence which could be
dangerous or could be awesome like Elon
Musk says that could be also ending baby
maybe it splits I see a divergence
happening I see one group going towards
the technology and one group going back
to the earth back to nature you know I
think that's that's what I see you just
became Elon Musk and Joe Rogan me and
him did mushrooms the night of that
podcast listening to it listening to you
on he's a trip he line is my biggest
hero right now really yeah I would say
really like his well actually you guys I
like even more thank you good guy I'm at
your disposal I just quit my job this
morning so if you guys want to go and
just tell me what to do you don't have
to pay me just tell me what to do with
help and I'll help you in any way I can
book it come talk this let's go to the
prisons and talk to the people in the
prisons I would be honored man I want
people you know I've been given a lot of
speeches for banks and all that and I
believe in our financial system I
believe in our banking system I believe
in the strength of our economy that's
not the point at all but I've only given
it like half way like what I want to do
now you know is go and help heal people
heal people like doctor said be dead you
know heal people I mean like Nipsey
Hussle sacrifice for what just happened
with that you know and but I want to go
to the scariest darkest places you know
and also spend the rest of my half of my
life in bliss and in heaven and with
people that I love scary's and darkest
places in the indigenous islands and
dizziness jungles and those I want to go
to you those we knew those we wouldn't
see the dark people you really yeah I
think so I think more prisons yeah you
know so the island off of India where no
one's allowed to go because there's this
tribe of people you know them on Terry
launched Spears and everybody that comes
close like so
do try this rain Christian Bible lit him
up in the arrows because he didn't
understand Jesus's message the
government doesn't allow people to go to
this island because they know they'll be
killed by these people and this dude was
like documenting for months that he was
going to come bring Christianity to
these people and enlighten them and he
got there and he was killed because he
was trying to take something there and
take away what they had exactly I think
we got to encourage people to go and
form their own belief structure you
perform your own hierarchy exactly but
then you know respect respect to each
other man I've learned so much from
Islam but I came from Christianity and I
spent most of my 20s you know as an
atheist yeah but now it's like I you
know ultimately I don't know but I'm on
that search and that seeking for like
I'm on like dr. sub'd I heard him say
like the object at the edge of the
horizon
like it's that's what I'm after that
light that's at the edge of the horizon
to go and chase that and that's what I
mean is that wherever we go then we help
people go in and pick that up
because you can be both at peace and you
can be at peace and you can be you can
be doing [ __ ] at the same time you know
we don't have to go and sit under a
Bodhi tree or whatever no you know I
read that I'm not very familiar with the
upon assad's but but that's basically
what it's about
from India right keep that book about
yes a book that's like the religious
book yes they haven't had real tales of
lines and warriors and Dragons and
worries I mean yes but that's
essentially what he talks about in there
you know you can be at peace but there's
also actions that need to be done you
know hmm was that with uh speaking of
maybe to close it out on a note but the
oh man what's the the quote from the
bhagavad-gita the guy that were to drop
the atomic bomb where he said I
come death yeah destroyer of worlds
yeah who they're after hi MA yeah up in
her banana that's what he said and they
dropped that
yeah and that's from basically the scene
one Krishna who is the wanted you
he's the divine God you know the God of
gods he reveals his true form and he's
everything you know he is everything and
he's got thousands of arms and heads and
legs and eyes and different skins and
all of that you know because he is
everything and death and to you know
it's all encompassed and one guy got a
woman one know a male the interesting
thing about ancient Hindu texts or that
they were very derogatory towards women
mainly that's know yeah a lot of the
ancient text periods where Tori Tori
obvious yes absolutely but they had
ancient queen Warriors Joe yes they did
and there's a lot of things about the
yoginis the yoginis were a tribe of
women who were mystics they talk about
these women flying and they would they
were basically killed off and demonized
and so that sort of began this
misogynistic view of women in India
mythology also did that Greek mythology
also did that with the Amazons yes and
there are real people yeah until I was
sort of um be there for the gravesites
got Amazon Queens oh yeah for sure I
never did think this I thought was just
mom folktale stuff then it was
discovered you know blew my mind how
crazy would it be if we found out what I
think where we came from
yeah who we are how did this happen yeah
what are ways the first two people who
was the first - how did this start
I didn't really start from sex the sex
was the only way that we could recreate
is it really maybe something about
recreating that we all know about
there's no sex is just too simple you
know is it that simple is to just two
idiots could make love and sex is pretty
awesome too you said sex next to be a
bunch of times sometime or the same
person well yes you know like that's why
we can live in like half of it can be
that you know in the other half it's
like you know impede a lady in the
streets freaking the sheets good yeah my
life one of the younger kid named I by I
had a bunch of [ __ ] orange eat all
the time just a bunch of chicks and guys
a [ __ ] everybody measure their
cameras thank you we live in a very cool
time I think it's the best time ever to
be alive right now you know because we
can we can create a life where you know
what maybe we get the robots to go and
do the work for us and that we just live
in bliss but maybe that goes the other
way either way we're getting the message
out there so you know it was an honor to
be here with you guys and I'm dead
serious from bottom of my heart
however I can help you in any way I like
you don't even have to ask just give me
a glance on there the same here journey
people that we meet on a journey leaving
this place right yeah that's what we are
journey just leaving this place just
keep finding more allies on our journey
like you find all these what you got man
20 years ago ten years ago
[ __ ] that's what we got to be grateful
for them mm-hmm man thank you guys [ __ ]
dude such an honor to have both of you
Kyle Jeff you're the [ __ ] man dude
thank you guys so much for your stories
and Cheryl targeted us everybody thank
you so much for tuning in remember to
subscribe to our You Tube channel
hotboxing with my man Mike Tyson
check us out on iTunes be told the truth
shall be towed
that's [ __ ] right Mike alright
everybody until next time we're out of
here
number one told station
[Music]